[Music]
nothing says britain more than
nope
nope
keep going
ah yes there it is a nice cup of tea
[Music]
we know we have china to thank for
introducing tea to the western world but
how did it make its way to england and
become the cultural obsession it is
today well that's all thanks to one
portuguese woman
the year 1662 the person
catherine of breganza she just won the
hand of england's king charles ii with
the help of a very large dowry including
money treasures and spices this
worthwhile trade made her the queen of
england scotland and ireland when she
arrived to her new homeland she brought
with her packets of loose leaf tea in
crates labelled transport de irvas
aromaticus
it's a theory that this was later
abbreviated to
t e a
t
now t could all be found in england but
was only rarely used for medicinal
purposes catherine continued drinking
tea to her heart's content and as the
new royal everything about her including
her beverage habits was copied by other
ladies desperate to be just like their
idol
another thing catherine brought to the
table from portugal was the idea of tea
drinking experience
she popularized the use of porcelain
teacups and mugs by the end of the 17th
century much of british aristocracy were
enjoying the hot beverage delightful and
soon enough so was everyone else today
while tea can be found pretty much
everywhere it remains a special daily
pastime for the brits
so carry on and drink tea people of
england
[Music]
you